[Musik]
ingeborg wolff ist 103 jahre alt aber
das sieht man ihr wirklich nicht an
[Musik]
ich habe meinen stil mit 22 23 gehabt
und damit den habe ich heute noch und
das ist sicher etwas was kaum eine frau
von sich behaupten können
hermann körper ist 100 jahre alt der
jüngste in diesem film mit seinem
elektromobil ist er jeden tag unterwegs
und hier
dieser große nußbaum machen wir unsere
füße
das ist hilde lehmann mit 102 jahren ist
sie immer noch unternehmungslustig und
hat ständig etwas vor
[Musik]
etwa 17.000 hundertjährige gibt es in
deutschland drei mal so viele wie im
jahr 2000
[Musik]
ingeborg wolff geht sicherheitshalber
mit zwei stöcken aber das tut ihrer
eleganz keinen abbruch sie bummelt gerne
durch die boutiquen von kronberg im
taunus in ein paar tagen wird sie als
model bei einem besonderen fotoshooting
auftreten
da wäre ein neues kleidungsstück
vielleicht ganz passend was ist denn das
hier
braun es in diesem jahr wieder ähnlich
das hat so einen großen ausschnitt kann
wurde er nicht mehr tragen sonst ist ein
schönes blau
seitdem ich alt bin weil ich viel mehr
auf ich habe mein leben lang im schatten
meines vaters gestanden dann habe ich im
schatten meines mannes gestanden
und jetzt sieht es so aus als ob ich
selber ein schatten schmeiße für das
fotoshooting hat sie nichts gefunden
aber sie besitzt ja genug leider frau
wolf ist nicht nur gut zu fuß auch am
steuer ihres autos wirkt sie sicher bis
heute fährt sie unfallfrei
ich fahre immer
das nehme ich mir diese freiheit hat er
lässt mich wie souverän geht's in die
parklücke und dann zeigt sie uns was sie
noch alles kann
disziplin ist alles einmal in der woche
geht sie zum training unter fachlicher
aufsicht zieht sie ihr workout durch
hälfte geschafft aber das glaubt ja nein
ja wohl genau und dann das gewicht
ich nehme mir rasch wie beweglich sie
halt noch ist ich sage immer dass sie
noch beweglicher ist als ich es jetzt
bin
das glaubt mir immer nicht aber es ist
tatsächlich so wichtig ist das
allerwichtigste
und ich glaube mit 103 können nicht mehr
so viele leute sich noch so bewegen wie
ich wenn hermann körper und seine frau
eleonore durch ihre heimatstadt das
fränkische kleinheubach spazieren fahren
werden erinnerungen an ihre jugend wach
die beiden verbrachten ihr ganzes leben
auf dem bauernhof kennen gelernt haben
sie sich kurz nach dem krieg
also ich bin aus der gefangenschaft
gekommen und bilden das auto rein und
hab die junges mädchen getroffen haben
gefragt hätte sie mir sagen wo der
baustelle wohnt 90 jahre gehen sie mit
ja das war unser erster bekanntschaft
die ausländer sind ja alle entlassen
worden
wir hatten russen erhalten bohlen
franzosen auf dem hof und dann hat mein
vater gesagt ich brauche weiter und dann
hat sich mein mann mir ochsenfurt
gemeldet dann haben wir uns
kennengelernt und und sucht sich haben
wir dann geheiratet
und jetzt sind es 8 60 jahren
und dann mache also hochzeit 30 alle ja
verglichen mit ihrem mann ist frau
körper noch jung gerade mal 88
gerne erinnert sie sich zurück an ihre
hochzeit drei tage noch dann ist das
genau 68 jahre her
hilde lehmann war nie verheiratet
sie arbeitete als näherin und bei der
bahn in ihrer wohnung in berlin lebt sie
allein
sie könnten ja auch essen liefern lassen
viel braucht die zierliche einen meter
38 kleine damen nicht um das meiste
kümmert sie sich noch selbst kochen
einkaufen nur zweimal in der woche kommt
jemand für die größeren besorgungen und
zum putzen
hilde lehmann interessiert sich für
vieles besonders für politik und sport
ihre große leidenschaft sind
schlittschuhfahren und rollschuhlaufen
1938 habe ich angefangen dass ich mir
rollstuhl geliehen habe weil ich das als
kind schon immer wollte weil ich bei den
verwandten in berlin gesehen habe dass
die kinder mögen rollt schon fix über
die straße rannten und das wollte ich
auch gerne aber da in meinem geburtsort
keine glatte bahn war dass ich heute
schon laufen konnte dann hat mein vater
mich getröstet warte bis du erwachsen
bist dann könnte die rolle zu kaufen und
wenn in der stadt bist da sind glatte
straßen da kannst du fahren
hab ich noch in der wohnung versteckt
nicht mehr da mein körper und sein e
mobil immer wenn das wetter es zulässt
fährt er in seinen garten in dem er obst
und gemüse anbaut
im sommer ist er jeden tag
[Musik]
kann sein denn ich bin ja auch wo wir
sagen nicht dass ich jetzt die ganzen
tage in der bude sitzt wenn ich ihnen
das buch ab dann geht es noch hab ich es
aber nicht da fahre ich dann schon mal
los vom mittagessen wird mittagsstunde
kalten kaffee getrunken und gewöhnlich
namen café zu den karriere nahm lothar
verschwinde ich nochmal und so glaube
ich schon in der gegend um hermann
körper wurde auf einem bauernhof in
polen geboren sein ganzes leben war er
mit begeisterung landwirt den hof hat er
mit 65 aufgegeben
nur der garten ist geblieben wurde von
keim gezwungen
ingeborg wolff fährt regelmäßig nach
frankfurt zu ihrer friseurin
sie mag etwas eitel sein eingebildet ist
sie nicht wieder ein bisschen jünger
vielen vielen dank muss ja nicht jeder
schön sagen ich gehöre nicht zu denen
gehören kann
aber ich war immer ein bisschen anders
ich war vielleicht immer ein bisschen
mehr ab habt und ich habe mich auch
immer gerne gut angezogen man kann ja
ein bisschen was aus sich machen und das
ist im prinzip gewesen
sie hat immer gearbeitet zuerst in einem
fotolabor später studierte sie
innenarchitektur
das war in den 50er jahren ungewöhnlich
viele jahre leitete sie ein exklusives
möbelgeschäft in frankfurt freunde von
mir bekommen am ersten oktober eine
wohnung eine zweitwohnung in frankfurt
und ich habe den grundriss bekommen und
ich finde diese geschichte wirklich
wegreißen ich habe hier erst mal alles
aus text und dann habe ich also hier
jetzt aufgemacht wenn ich was zu denken
habe in meinem beruf dann bin ich
wirklich hey hilde lehmann genießt die
annehmlichkeiten der großstadt am
liebsten isst sie mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln unterwegs im bus durch
berlin
heute will sie zum kiez spaziergang mit
dem bürgermeister ihres stadtteils auch
wenn sie den ganzen weg nicht mehr
schafft beim start ist sie fast immer
dabei heute mit kamera
[Applaus]
hermann körper und seine frau bei der
morgendlichen zeitungslektüre um auf dem
laufenden zu bleiben hat der körper ein
lesegerät angeschafft so kann er sich
trotz sehschwäche informieren was
interessiert sie denn so die zeitungen
lesen welche themen
momentan heißt dass sport das ist
richtig und was sagen dass lokale ehe
was sie in der gegend passiert das
interessiert mich nicht
sehen sie das wie hat sich die welt
entwickelt naja gut okay die welt in
europa hat sich jan hoch weil man sagen
so ihrem vortrag entwickelte nicht war
aber allgemein die welt wenn man sagen
den lernstand geguckt wo elend und
unterdrückung und so resch das ist keine
runges platz um das wohl der körpers
kümmert sich ihre tochter doris seit sie
nicht mehr arbeitet wohnt sie wieder bei
ihren eltern müssen sich nun mal umhören
was passiert in den heimen ich habe ganz
schlechte erfahrung ganz schlechte
erfahrung mit entfernten verwandten und
auch kurzzeitpflege bei meiner tante
werde ich das leider nicht anders
beruflich einrichten ließ sie musste zur
kurzzeitpflege und das würde ich meine
eltern nie zu noten nie
es ist wie sie erstrebenswert auch
dieses alte zu erreichen
das ist schwierig ich finde es schön alt
zu sein aber in meinem fall glaube ich
möchte ich es nicht weil es gibt
niemanden der
sich um nichts kümmern wird ich habe
keine tochter die dann zu mir zieht und
sich um nichts kümmern zu den mahlzeiten
sitzen sie alle zusammen so wie früher
auch ursula die andere tochter kommt
täglich vorbei zu hause bei ingeborg
wolff im seniorenzentrum
morgen soll das fotoshooting sein dem
sie seit wochen entgegen fiebert als
junge frau wurden schon mal porträts von
ihr gemacht lange ist das her
ob sie heute noch eine gute figur macht
vor der kamera
hier im heim hat sie eine eigene wohnung
in ihrem haushalt erledigt sie alles
noch selbst
nein im seniorenheim will ich vor aber
es muss ja keiner wissen dass ein
seniorenheim ist es ist wie bei mir zu
hause alles ein bisschen zäh kleine
erzeuger und ein bisschen länger
nix für rollatoren ich werde immer
gefragt warum sollen sie keinen rollator
ich will auf keinen fall ein erstens
musste ich in teppiche wegnimmt und dann
könnte ich mich hier nicht mehr umdrehen
das bild nicht
als innenarchitektin ist ihr eine schöne
einrichtung wichtig sie kann es sich
leisten
ihr verstorbener mann hat als arzt gut
verdient sie war immer berufstätig glück
findet sie auch in den kleinen dingen
die schokolade ist mein kraftfutter und
wenn ich sie mir versagt ihm vielleicht
ein pfund abzunehmen oder so denn nach
drei tagen habe ich schlechte laune
die körpers machen einen familienausflug
heute sind wichtige dinge zu besprechen
[Musik]
zu ihrem 68
hochzeitstag wollen die beiden töchter
den eltern etwas schenken
eine fahrt an einem besonderen ort
langweilige strecke aber der papa auf
die 19
dann ist es hier du hast du möchtest
spazieren fahren dann ist doch ein umweg
völlig egal
ach so auch ich freue mich darauf dass
ich endlich mal diesen ort genau aussehe
ich meine ich bin den ort wo meine
mutter herkomme aber ich weiß jetzt
nicht wo der ort jetzt genau war wo sie
dem papa begegnet ist das finde ich sehr
romantisch hilde lehmann hat wieder
etwas vor
ihre 73 jährige tochter sabine ist aus
mainz zu besuch
die beiden machen einen ausflug in den
geburtsort der mutter nach falkenberg
elster in der lausitz zum 25 jubiläum
des eisenbahnmuseums
freust du dich ja ich freue mich sehr
dass ich nach so vielen jahren noch mal
hingehen und das ist in diesem jahr noch
schaffen
die fahrt im auto verlangt ihr einiges
ab aber sie beschwert sich nicht
hauptsache sie kommt gut an
[Gelächter]
direkt neben dem bahnhof ganz nah an den
gleisen ist sie aufgewachsen
wahrscheinlich rührt daher ihre
begeisterung für alles was mit der bahn
zu tun hat ist das foto in dem daten
hier gemacht ist es hier gemacht das
jahr ja also wir stehen jetzt praktisch
an der stelle wo dieses foto geworden
das für mich war toll
haben sie eine schöne kindheit hier eine
sehr schöne mein vater der sehr für uns
gesorgt hat mit spielzeug werden
wunderbare laube daher springt von
sandkasten beide großen reisen war noch
eine besondere reise und das also
selbstverständlich
auf dem fest des eisenbahnmuseums trifft
sie familie und alte freunde
[Musik]
diese schwarze lok ist die attraktion
des tages
hilde möchte unbedingt mit auch wenn der
einstieg zur kletterpartie wird obwohl
sie arthrose und schmerzen hat klagt sie
nicht das abenteuer ist es wert
[Musik]
die lok gilt als echtes museumsstück
dabei ist 27 jahre jünger als hilde
lehmann mit ihren 102
[Musik]
jetzt noch aussteigen
für die alte dame ein waghalsiges und
nicht ungefährliches unterfangen ein
bisschen
eine fabrikhalle in der nähe von
frankfurt
hier findet heute das lang erwartete
fotoshooting mit frau wolf statt
tolle lippen haben sie aber die papiere
über die lippen ist ganz schrecklich
voller falten ach was sehen
ich trage die haare gerne ein bisschen
würde da nicht so frisiert
am liebsten wäre es jetzt noch mal so
machen hallo frau wolff willkommen in
meinem studio also das ist hervorragend
links das ist die erika die wurde
überall ausgestellt die hat quasi als
modell eine weltkarriere gemacht dass
sie jetzt noch vor sich haben ich kaufe
alle meine sachen allein und sie macht
meinen haushalt weitestgehend allein ich
nicht darf ich mal abziehen
ok karsten thormaehlen ist berühmt für
seine fotos von menschen über 100 für
sein buchprojekt hat er sie auf der
ganzen welt getroffen
[Gelächter]
also frau wolf ist definitiv eine
ausnahmeerscheinung sie sie ist die
erste die mich hier auch im studio
besuchen kommt bisher bin ich zu den
leuten immer hingefahren auf der ganzen
welt ja und die bild ausbeute ist auch
eine ganz andere muss ich sagen heute
macht riesengroßen spaß mit ihr
das haben der weg recht ich kann mich
immer noch freuen
ich kann auch noch unendlich viel freude
erleben wenn ich reise oder so ich hab
noch nach bilbao auf haben
ich sage ja immer hier milch vor habe
desto besser funktioniert
die fotos zeigen es deutlich ingeborg
wolff ist eine schöne frau bin ich das
wirklich heute und gestern
man erkennt es noch die nase ist ein
bisschen dicker geworden da muss auch
noch ein bisschen größer
das kind ist faltiger geworden die ohren
sind größer geworden dass frank 80 jahre
sind es genau
hochzeitstag nummer 68
[Musik]
an dieser kreuzung begegnete sich das
paar zum ersten mal auch wenn seither
viele jahre vergangen sind hat hermann
körper diesen moment noch genau in
erinnerung
und was sollen wir jetzt das ist das ist
zum beispiel nicht realistisch die osta
getroffen haben nicht wahr
da hab ich gefragt entschuldige bitte
movies zu bestellen und wenig umarmungen
und küssen sich war
ja ich bin ja ich spiele von dagegen
kommen bin auf der linken seite
marschiert war ja auch war ja auch
damals noch kein verkehr
das ist kann ich mir noch erinnern du
bist in der mittelstraße
weil du bist etwas oder kommt man dann
gucke ich mir noch nie vorher passiert
kommt nicht im rucksack auf google dass
das war für dich herum sahara mal
langsam entlassene soldat und fand sie
ihn nicht damals schon hübsch fast ob
ich bereits gefunden hätte tja das ist
eine angelegenheit die haben sich ins
maul zerrissen
sonsbeck schon längst abgehoben hatte
ja
[Musik]
der 100 jährige und seine frau seit 68
jahren ein ehepaar die habe ich schon
mir 50 auf 55 4 traurig dass ich mit 70
auch führen musste denn werden eine
sportkameraden die über 90 noch sie
zugelaufen ist ja ich wollte es doch
auch mal
ich wollte ja auch noch schaffen heute
wird frau lehmann von einer bekannten zu
einer eislauf gala gebracht eingeladen
dazu wurde sie von der früheren
weltmeisterin christine stühler rat
ihrer langjährigen freundin eislaufen
kann hilde lehmann nicht mehr
aber diese besucher an der eisfläche
sind ihre besonderen glücksmomente
[Musik]
super dann überraschung
[Gelächter]
jahrzehntelang hat sich hilda als
trainerin ehrenamtlich um die jüngsten
im als sport gekümmert
[Musik]
ist das schön das ist kleinlich so viel
mühe geben
mitmachen der fußball muss jemand da
sein der klatsch klatsch für freunde
sich durch
[Musik]
das ist ja ganz prima und sie hat keine
ahnung dass gleich noch etwas schöneres
kommen wird
[Musik]
es ist gut wenn du herr zu lassen
möchte ich mit dir auch noch mal aufs
eis
[Musik]
offen interessiert und immer bereit
etwas zu wagen
das leben ist voller überraschungen für
hilde lehmann ist auch mit 102 noch
nicht schluss
[Musik]